- Hi guys.
- We are very February.
- Right?
- Yes!
- We didn't plan this, but I feel like
we're very coordinated.
- I know!
And I love it.
- We are very February,
I love it.
- [Lily] We are very February.
- It is lovely to meet you!
- You too!
- 'Cause we have
been in an elevator once,
and we both, this is a real story.
- [Lily] This is a true story, y'all.
- We, and first of all, I'm so sorry,
have you met Peter yet?
- We haven't--
- We just met.
- But now we have.
- Okay.
Now you're besties.
- Now we're best friends.
- Anyway, so we, this is a real story,
we were on an elevator once,
we used to live in the same condo.
I'd heard, she's also,
if you don't know this,
she's also married to
Caleb from Kings of Leon,
and I had heard that y'all
lived in the building,
and I had never seen you,
and so all of a sudden
I'm in the elevator, and
you're like with a stroller,
you know I couldn't see it,
because we all were looking down,
but you could feel the
vibe of rock and roll.
Like, you enter a place and
you're like, "I don't belong."
They were so cool.
And I was in the elevator
and I was literally like,
"Should I say anything?"
And I don't look like
me, I had no makeup on,
my weave was gone, no lashes,
I did not look like me.
- Same, also.
- And so, you were
thinking the same thing?
- We, literally, 'cause
Kelly had just covered
my husband's song, "Use Somebody,"
and we'd just watched it that morning,
and she is standing in front
of us, and Caleb is so shy,
and I'm like, "Caleb, Caleb, Caleb!"
(audience laughs)
And he's like closing his eyes, he's like,
"I'm not gonna say it!"
I'm like, "Tell her you like the song!"
And we were all like,
"Who's gonna say hi first?"
And then Kelly walks off, and I'm like,
"Caleb, why didn't you say anything?"
- And I did it
because I'm not gonna go
to the rock and roller
and be like, "What's up dude?"
I'm not kidding, it's never gonna happen.
- He was so blown away by,
we both are so blown away,
but he loved that cover.
- I am blown away by him,
I've seen him actually a few times,
in Nashville, and you
live in my favorite city!
- We live in Nashville, I know!
- So wait, your first,
okay, this is crazy,
your first Sports
Illustrated swimsuit cover
was with Chrissy Teigen.
- Chrissy is hilarious
and Nina is so sweet,
and we had so much fun on that shoot.
I mean, we were just
giggling the whole time.
And also--
- That's so fun!
- It was covered with
sea cucumbers under us,
so it's like we look all sexy
but we were trying not
to step on sea cucumbers!
It was riddled, which is
a fact about this shoot.
Not sexy at all, are sea cucumbers.
- Oh my god!
I love how glorious it looks
and you don't know the backstory to that.
- Yeah, there was no glamor behind that.
- That would have been a fun
shoot though, she is hilarious.
- She is.
- But why did you create a fragrance?
- You know, I just love
beauty, I love fashion
and beauty and all that fun stuff,
and I was just lucky enough
to get to create this beautiful
fragrance, and, whoop!
- Nope, we've glued it down.
- Glued down, y'all.
- It's glued down.
You cannot touch
your fragrance.
- One, two, no.
- Here you go.
You can touch your fragrance now.
There's your fragrance.
- This is so--
- This one's down too.
Just kidding.
- I feel like I'm gonna like--
- So what's your, there's
two of them though, right?
- Yes, so I created this fragrance,
and Haven is the first one
which is based on Nashville
and my love of Nashville, and
it's very floral and feminine,
and this one, Summit,
is leather and tobacco
and really just yummy and intoxicating.
They're very different.
- Is that supposed to
be more the male one?
Because that's kind of more,
I love that.
- Yeah, me too,
it's a gender--
- Gender-neutral?
- Gender-neutral scent,
my husband loves that one,
and they're just fun,
and it's fun to create beautiful things.
- I love colognes and perfumes, I love it.
'Cause you can literally
feel like total crap
and then you spray it
and you're like all right, it's a new day.
- I'm good.
- You know what,
I'd give you a spritz--
- I'm happy.
- But it's glued down.
- I was going to spray it on all of you!
- Oh!
- But now I can't.
- It's glued down, I was gonna
give you a spritz but now--
- I don't need to go
home smelling like that.
(audience laughs)
- I loved your story.
- Or it's just going to be the 36 years.
- I'm not going to get to
37 if I come home like that.
- You're like, "There was this
model, she was spraying me
"with perfume, I swear!"
- Honey, I swear.
- There was this beautiful
Sports Illustrated model,
this is an amazing story.
- She was on the cover of the--
Watch!
- This hideous cover, ugh!
- [Kelly] That's actually a great story.